yeah
just before we get started I'll read our
emergency evacuation announcement should
we be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave by the nearest
available exit of the chamber our
assembly point is in the public carpark
at the side of the Civic suite please
don't delay your evacuation by
collecting belongings and please do not
return into the building until
permission is to do so is given by
Council staff please also note that the
meeting won't be audio recorded and as
usual Mobile's too silent or off please
formally good evening everybody members
and all our visitors to the Development
Committee on the 29th of August 2019
[Music]
just for all our visitors tonight the
way in which the various items work is
that the officers will do a presentation
then any speakers that are registered
will present then any of our non counts
or non committee member kautz
will be able to speak should they wish
then it who miss the one about the
mobile saying there then it won't be
open to the committee to have their
debate and ultimately make a decision
I'm sure during the course of the
presentations and the events there will
be things that you hear that you agree
with and some that you disagree with
however there isn't any opportunity for
general contribution and it is important
that everyone is heard and that the
meeting flows subject to proper protocol
and so please do restrain yourself if
you feel something has been said that
your you don't don't agree with one
small adjustment to the agenda I believe
most people are here for cambro clothes
item number eight so we'll take that as
the the first full item apologies for
item upon
it's cancer hi just mentioned proper
protocols you know I'm gonna say next
I'm sure which is a genders can only be
changed on the vote of the committee I'm
sure they're coming to a vote for it but
pretty pretty discussing with a number
of a number of members in a bad
is there anyone got any significant
objection to that members
no thank you item one is apologies for
absence there are non item two subsidy
yet substitute members there are non non
members attending I've seen councillor
Dre councillor row counts the Steptoe
counts the sparing counts the Wilkinson
counselor mr. Howie counts the
Mississauga council um McPherson
councillor Stanley got apologies
Riger okay
councillor Carol's got off hold you then
normally cuts things to the wire with
his arrival so I just assumed he was
doing that item for his minutes of the
meeting held on 27th of June 2019 you
happy for me to sign those as a correct
and accurate record of that meeting
thank you alright item 5 declarations of
interest let's start with the
non-members first councillor sparing you
don't need to stand up for this while
Thank You counselor bro that's the dre
Thank You counselor snapped our new
chairman I've got a number of afraid to
apologize with glass to item six an
opportunity interest I'm a member of
Barling Magna Parish Council and also
Essex County Council and I live in
little Wakering Road but the other end
to where the application is with regards
to item seven non-korean interest with
as a member of Essex County Council item
8 another other peculiar interest as
chairman of the investment board and I
will be leading the meeting at the start
of the debate and with regards to item 9
again as Essex County Council member
okay thank you okay
Thank You chairman and non-pecuniary
item number six I live in little waking
Road but this will not affect where I
live because I'm further up the road
thank you all right so our members now
that's
can suddenly okay
that's Lucas kale okay thank you
that's the Merrick cancer watan I
tonight chairman non-pecuniary interest
in respective eight by virtue of having
just been appointed portfolio holder and
having not taken part in any of the
meetings or discussions leading to it
okay yeah there's that's a rough day
okay cancer Williams
counselor sure okay cus America
okay thank you members just one other
slight slight amendment since last forum
council we've got a two and a half hour
time limit on this so yeah hopefully it
won't be a problem but as we get near at
that time we'll review where we are and
the likelihood of us progressing right
the way through so then our first item
is item eight there is some information
on the addendum for this one which you
should all already have had access to
land adjacent to 14 cambro close Raley
thank you chairman and the application
site is a vacant open plot of land
located on the northern side of hamburg
close in a prominent position at the end
of avista when entering hamburg close
the starting site is opening nature and
comprises a sycamore tree this trees not
covered by a tree preservation order
planning permission is being sought to
erect a two-story building comprising
two self-contained flats layout of a
streetcar parking and private amenity
space and bins doors the proposed
building would follow the linear
building line along Hamburg close the
proposed appearance of the building and
its layout scale bulk and height would
not appear this dissimilar to its
surrounding contact and is considered
acceptable as it would not result in to
monster harm to the character appearance
the area and it is considered that there
is sufficient distance between the
proposed building and the existing
residential properties to the east and
west it is considered that a development
of two flats could be accommodate within
the site that would not result in a
detrimental impact upon the occupiers
and neighboring properties by way of
causing excessive overshadowing as a
result of overbearing or causing
overlooking a lot of Jersey on one side
with the aircon as well I'm just bring
the mic a bit closer to you as well
Thanks
and okay I will continue bin storage
would be provided in recessed areas set
up in the side elevation a shared usable
minute II space or 62 square meters
would be provided to the rear of the
building and this would be in accordance
with the 25 square meters of sheds space
a flat required body SPD to car parking
is laid out to the rear which is not
dissimilar from the current layout of
the surrounding street scene access is
gained off Hamburg closed whereby there
would be an area of hard standing laid
out to accommodate for car parking
spaces the access is considered
acceptable and would not not have an
impact upon highway safety the proposal
involves full car parking spaces for two
two-bedroom flats to be laid out which
measures in a quantum the minimum
dimensions 2.5 by 5 meters set out in
the parking standards this site would
not be able to provide a visitor space
but the short for one or street car
parking space would not be significant
there are enough car parking spaces
proposed of insight said the proposed
dwellings in addition there are also no
parking restriction on Hamburg closed
and most properties have off street car
parking for two cars or more therefore
the proposed development is considered
acceptable and would not have a
detrimental impact upon highway safety
or a free flow traffic would be
materially harmed a cycle store has been
incorporated into the rear garden that
would accommodate for cycle spaces which
is because it is adequate for the scalar
development proposed the dwellings
proposed comply of internal dimension
set out in the National Technical Stan
housing standards if you can read the
picture the tree that exists was would
have to be removed to facilitate the
development and offers some mini value
given its location
however the tree would not qualify for
attention due to its species of the tree
being a sycamore and would not score
highly on the tree evaluation method
preservation order and therefore no
objections are raised to the removal of
this tree a condition has been
recommended by the council's our culture
officer to require suitable species to
be planted to the amenity space
following completion of the intensive
phase of development as
soft landscaping thing a scheme the
proposed development is found acceptable
and would not I would call it both
national and local policies and adopted
supplementary planning documents and
therefore is recommended for approval
subject to conditions as stated on page
8.1 or the agenda thank you okay our
first speaker on this one it's Daniel
cross who's the agent up to five minutes
we've just turned the microphone on just
a time you can sit down
so I'm Daniel cross from front
architecture with the agent for the site
got a few things sorry a few comments in
response to some of the resident
objections that have been raised so the
application has gained officer officer a
support the National Planning Policy
Fame framework encourages the effective
use of land to provide much-needed
housing the officers stated in principle
the development of this site is
appropriate to deliver such housing
parking requirements are met internal
floor areas exceed national minimums and
amenity areas offer an over provision
which suggests a suitable quantum of
development therefore the site is not
over developed and the density is
acceptable the proposed development is
equal to surrounding dwellings in height
and scale it takes the appearance of a
detached dwelling and therefore is in
keeping with the neighboring area the
officer's report states the application
site offers enough car parking spaces to
serve the proposed dwellings therefore
parking levels have been accepted the
site provides two vehicle spaces per
dwelling and therefore would not affect
existing residence these spaces are
located in an existing grass area that
should not currently be used for parking
by neighboring residents the proposals
do not force new residents to park on
the street and provides a parking
solution within the application boundary
which should not affect the existing
parking situation of how a closed
the scheme does not provide additional
parking for neighboring houses and there
is no planning guidance to suggest the
application should look to provide
parking for surrounding houses although
it may be frustrating that existing
properties do not benefit from allocated
parking it is not for the current
application to address this as it is
outside the ownership boundary if the
new residents do not have if new
residents do not have to park outside
the application site this should be
enough to justify an adequate parking
solution the proposed amenity space
provides a focal entrance point to an
area of predominantly faced with
reoffending providing natural
surveillance over Hamburg close a full
landscaping strategy will be provided as
part of the approval highlighting
proposed planting schedules and
maintenance plans to offer a visually
attractive shared amenity space
providing visual enhancement for the
street this is a welcome condition
stated in the officer's report the
officer's report confirms that the
application proposes do not encroach on
BRE 45-degree guidance with regards to
daylight and sunlight and therefore will
have no detrimental effect on the
amenities of adjacent properties the
proposal has gained officer support
considering the above points and as such
provides an opportunity to deliver
suitable housing on an underused site
with an improvement to the visual
appearance of Hamburg close thank you
thank you our second speaker is Jill way
again up to five minutes I'll let you
know when you've got a minute to go
mics on already so that's okay thank you
be time to speak here this evening I'm
representing the Hamburg closed
community most of them here this evening
I'd like to note first of all that
previous applications have been made in
2004 and were refused they refused on
the basis they would lose a passel of
informal space in the prominent town
landscape and be harmful to the
character and immunity of the area
nothing has changed it's still the same
space oh thank you putting up the
pictures national policy framework says
develops do not undermine quality of
life improve the quality they must
improve the quality and character of the
existing community are in the way it
functions this is going to have a severe
impact we are losing our open space we
are losing as you point Lee said space
that we'd like to park because there's
no other parking I'll point out that the
report is inaccurate it says that every
member of Hamburg close has two or more
parking spaces allocated to them we
don't we have 20 spaces and two
driveways
that's one unallocated parking space is
on a first-come first-served basis hence
why the neighbors anyone else on free
parking can park anywhere they want in
this road and we have difficulties
getting in by taking away this area of
land makes it more difficult for us and
by giving it someone else right not your
problem but it is an issue for us it's
providing a detrimental impact on the
landscape and character of the
environment it's going to avoid a loss
of open space for the local development
framework committee Mandarin dm3
infilling nothing's changed it's still
going to impact on us the core strategy
each one says council will insist resist
intensification of small sites in order
to protect the character resisting
servants and settlements nothing's
changed DM trees and Woodlands diem25
conserve and enhance existing trees and
Woodlands noka logical environmental
studies been done no Trevor surveys been
completed and the report can't decide if
it's rural or urban its rural the tree
doesn't qualify for attention for it's a
sycamore
a sycamore is one of the best trees for
air pollution is a 50 year old tree it's
being cut down when this committee is
wanted not this committee this whole
council is
saying they want to be carbon neutral by
2013 the first thing they do is cut down
a tree and the next thing they're going
to do is to put development on there of
which the planner under EMV 9
sustainable homes must meet zero carbon
targets please explain where you cut
down a tree and then ask a developer to
build something on it and have carbon
neutral needs species and habitat D m27
proposal should not cause harm to
protected species and habitats we're in
a rural area there is an impact on the
wildlife protected species such as bats
and birds which are lapwings I think I
named a Kingfisher I could have been
wrong when I sent you earlier it was a
woodpecker national parenting promisee
framework safe inclusive isn't
accessible to promote health and
well-being you're about to demolish that
that's what we need we have children
have it special needs who cannot get to
the access to green parks around the
corner they can't cross the road they're
very vulnerable they're protected under
the Equality Act
they've DLA is in eh CPS taking out that
land where they could just play I have a
beautiful view see the horses which are
on the back of it these can be detriment
to the health and impact on them as I
showed in the study I sent to you the
ADHD is improved and reduces stimming
isn't included because they're at an
open space to play in and they love the
trees and it helps on obesity I said
about the parking standards there's no
restrictions that means the free pop-up
for everybody thanks to the parking of
hambar hill and all visitors to the area
there's limited emergency services and
at three times this year I think it was
we couldn't even get an ambulance in
luckily your husband was ok so we have
very big difficulties in our road by
doing this it's going to make it more
awkward equality impact assessment which
I have received and I have got the
details so thank you for that and Marcus
Hassan sent to me there's no impact
positive or negative on the actual
building but it will have a positive and
negative effect this was an original
housing estate of 22 houses we've still
got 40% of social housing that makes up
20% in the entire Trinity Ward's social
housing
we've got loan parents single mums we've
got old people we've got family what
with disabled badges I think we've got
three we've got five that actually are
officially disabled as well they're all
going to be impacted by ruling that they
all will be impacted they won't have
space they only have one space each this
is giving a new development which only
have two
people vs. 22 people go space the flood
risk says on the planning application it
won't be affected
it will you're about to cut down a tree
if you cut down a tree you can increase
the flooding if you cut down the tree
and build something on it the soak away
doesn't work we are flooding two or
three times a year whenever this
flooding we're on a hill we haven't
appropriate deign it drainage the soak
away doesn't work so to say you're going
to do it was soaked away isn't good
enough and the tree survey we were told
by the conservation officer
it wasn't an attractive tree is what he
wrote in the reports are therefore it
doesn't matter doesn't matter how
attractive it is it's helping you for
carbon offset so why on earth would you
say that's your reason I think I've
covered everything other than the fact
we don't have been storage we have to
park it outside for a health hazard and
we're out of a cycle store we just
chained to a lamppost thank you for time
thank you
[Applause]
first of all non members that
syndicators canceled a row Thank You
chairman
now you can wait on the debate starts
Thank You chairman I and my colleagues
in Trinity would have made sure that the
assistant director responsible for Asus
was aware of the contentious issues in
respect of this site an application for
this site was expected to come before
this committee long before now
but we as ward councillors were not
happy with the information put before us
the assistant director listened to us
and we were made and we've made sure
that residents were given the
opportunity meet to meet with us and
some did we also made sure that
residents were kept in touch with what
was going on I also advise the speaker
here tonight that she had the chance to
speak here and I'm glad she did thank
you
however that said this is a piece of
land owned by the council who have the
right to put in such applications but my
concerns are and all are and always have
been flooding on that site we know
there's been flooding there before and
it will continue unless something
drastic is done we need absolute
assurance that this will be addressed
and whilst I am aware that then this is
not a planning application my next issue
is parking again I have suggested to the
residents fagio that they apply for
parking restrictions in this road the
parking is appalling parking from other
roads residents in Han bro Hill leaves
them with no spaces at all as I said
earlier it is a first-come first-served
basis thank you German lizard cancer mr.
hoi Thank You chairman I'll just
concentrate on one thing I think it was
interesting to hear the speaker was no
it's very good obviously and one of my
favorite topics is parking as you're
aware this doesn't meet the standard in
a number of ways the size should be 2.9
by 5 point 5 meters these I believe two
point no three meters by 5 meters so the
plot the sizes for the car parking
spaces provided or undersized
I'm aware that we all always come up
with the argument that well the minimum
is 2.9 by 5 but I don't think that is
acceptable we are the council we should
be adhering to our policies and I think
this should adhere to our policies it's
easy if we don't adhere to our policies
why should anyone else it is missing the
one visitor space without that visitor
space it makes the parking even worse so
I think there should be refused on the
basis of parking on the issue of the
undersized parking spaces and on the
basis that there is a missing parking
space so there is one parking space
missing the these standards on minimum
standards they're not maximum so the
minimum is five spaces this is not a
main urban area which is the only time
you can restrict the number of spaces
you may go under then but it's clearly
not some Manor of an area there are no
buses nearby your honor you're not on
the bus route it's you can't be regarded
as that with regards to the parking lots
going to race this obviously the
building of these two properties in the
parking spaces on that green area that
would even discounting the fact that
cars parked on the green area you're
losing two spaces along the road
immediately where the drop curb will be
put in there be cars coming off of there
so you lose in two residents car parking
spaces already as as being said there
are only 20 car parking spaces on the
road for residents which are allocated
this is this the estate was built at a
time when we had lacks a parking
standard shall I say look at the
problems that caused I don't think we
should be lacks in adhering to our own
policies in this area I will leave it
there for this point thank you cheering
yeah yes sir welcome sir
Thank You Sharon I want to make one
point the in five point three of the
report it talks about the additional
housing should not be detrimental to the
character appearance of the locality who
then goes on particularly in five eight
to talk about whilst principle of
housing development it's not objected to
the main issues for consideration relate
to the acceptability of the development
as an infill development including
issues of scale and impact on character
as well as impacts on the residential
community we look back at a documents
I've got here data the 19th of February
2004 for the previous application there
were two grounds for refusal only one
has been dealt with one the one that's
been dealt with was the number of
parking spaces because that was from
more houses or form or flats rather but
the first reason for refusal says the
proposed loss of the parcel of informal
open space in this prominent townscape
landscape would be harmful to the
character and amenity of the area are
therefore have to ask German what has
changed because I can't see what has
changed thank you yeah there are any
more non members wishing to speak to any
of our members that have declared an
interest wish to say anything before
they leave right it's time you can go
yeah
[Music]
remembers your turn anyway ma'am okay
castle Wilson
Thank You chairman I'm gonna amplify
some of the points that have been made
by visiting members in particular
councilor Michael hi it's I believe it's
important we do stick to our own
standards and one of the things that
came out of the officers report to me
was that we wouldn't be complying with
their own standard DM 30 as an as a
question I noticed that Essex Highways
haven't been consulted on this is there
any reason for that they were consulted
but just never come ere commented on the
application thank you the reason why I
ask is because following on from counsel
the highest points about the parking
spaces I would have thought that Essex
highways would have an interest because
if you look at the photograph in front
of us you'll see that there's a lamppost
which is owned by six highways and if
you look at that that then would change
the layout of the parking so what we'll
be doing is you're actually coming on to
Park side by side so you're actually
limiting that the amount of space that
you've got there
that's one consideration and also
presumably that lights been put there
for a purpose for lighting obviously but
but there must be some reason why they
put the lamp post in that position
Stanley
this is
from the 2004 application
and since then he's become quite a
parked area and it sparked so much so
that that land is being used for for
girls because nobody else can park
anywhere else in that road and that this
where that their post is at the moment
he's take the t-junction which gives
life to that teen Junction leading into
Han bro Hill as it was put out and I
greet with be counsel from the 2004 the
objections that were put in and why it
was refused I totally agree with that
and and we should acknowledge even there
and Eddie's got worse since but we
should actually acknowledge that this is
a possible and that we really can't do
anything with other than Tony leave it
as he is for the amenity of the
neighborhood and a few parking spaces
for those that can get their cars in
nowhere else I think that we're making a
big mistake and plus the fact that the
parking is not adequate it's not of our
policy our policy describes what the
party should be and we should stick to
the policy we might policy then we
should stick to policy if we're going to
reduce that policy by size or whatever
then hey well I have a policy at the
beginning thank you very much and I
cannot support this application if you
could make a comment about the the
parking standard and then the
relationship between on street parking
and the parking out at the planning
application and then the streetlight and
okay FDM 30 actually requires
development to not have an impact on
highway safety and so that's kind of a
starting point then we look at the SPD
the power parking standards that are
adopted and that does require minimum
parking space to be 2.9 by 5 meters
which this does me just say in certain
circumstances in this case and you can
look at the context of the character of
the area and look at what the car
parking situation is a moment and
parking sizes so you know it does comply
in that respect with regards to the
lamppost
obviously the development need to apply
for permission to County get to get it
or even that would be at their cost
understand it's there at the moment
because there's never open space and it
is a t-junction but that could be
removed with permission from county at a
cost to the developer okay I've got
counts the Western next about one go
Thank You chairman can you is there a
picture of the plane of the the site
because I am considered I am concerned
about the parking I'd like to know where
you're going to put these parking spaces
for these flights because in the one
page of 8.8 it says access is gained or
Pam Pro closed whereby there would be an
area of haast and it laid out for full
car parking spaces so I'll be only gonna
have four are we having more and
whereabouts are they going to be please
Thank You Sharon they are accessed off
handbrake close as you pull into the
close and if you can see from the plan
in front of you there are four car
parking spaces laid out and to the sort
of real amenities base if you can see
that properly
counselor Watson Thank You chairman I've
driven into this road on two occasions
at separate times during the day and you
look across and you say well what a nice
piece of open space at the time the that
area was designed I'm sure that the
residents moved into it partly because
of the enjoyment of a bit of open space
you live in a street and isn't it nice
to see a bit of green amongst the
building area I accept that as the years
move on policies change and sometimes we
have to concede that we are obliged to
follow current policies rather than what
was in place at the time of the
development the difference between this
building and the one in 2004 is that
there were four dwellings versus the
nail too but the reality of life in 2019
are moving forward is that people have
normally two or three cars irrespective
of the number of bedrooms that they have
they have visitors and the reality is in
that road already there is significant
parking at all times of the day and I
really do look at it and say if this
were not council owned land we would
probably be saying isn't it a classic
example of where we're trying to squeeze
more property into relatively small
areas of length so in terms of my view
of it is I think it is a real shame that
we are looking at an area like this to
squeeze in property that said I do
accept within this committee we have to
be guided by officers in terms of
planning at law current planning law
because of the consequences of it being
taken to appeal if we don't comply with
that but I would urge us to look very
very carefully because I do not believe
that the current layout is as attractive
as it could be Thank You chair clear
account to Stanley you wish to come back
we cancel assembly that's not a fair
point please please make your point
remembers we've we've got an application
in front of us we have a great number of
planning policies that we are bound
duty-bound to implement from what I've
heard and from what I've read in the
report the principle of housing on that
site where whether desirable or not is
it's not really question the print the
principle is acceptable the parking
standards in terms of size although not
meeting our ideal are met but we are one
space short visitors and I think the the
crux of the the issues raised are around
that the the tightness of the parking
and and this application not providing
that that single space to refuse an
application on the lack of provision of
a single parking space is a challenge it
really is a challenge and I think it is
for members to take a view on that
particular issue most of all so I'll
take any final points before we go to a
vote on that one
councillor Wilson thank chairman it's a
point that was raised by councillor
Hawaii but there are already vehicles at
partly so there are two vehicles and a
number of the photographs you'll see
there's two vehicles parked parallel so
that the pavement or other times live
actually visited where there are two
vehicles parked on the green so though
in theory and I agree what you say that
we lose it that we're going to be one
parking space short in fact we won't it
will be three because we'll be taking
away to the existing parking spaces so
we're actually three down that that that
is not a precise planning issue where
where people are parking at the moment
we've got to focus on on this
application
and it's compliance with our planning
standards rules and regulations so it is
quite tight or more time cancel button
chairman in thank you for that in the
light of my earlier comments which to a
large extent are emotional rather than
objective what I would appreciate is
clear guidance on the parking situation
because clearly we have a a serious
decision to make in the light of our
current planning policies and I would
just like some very clear guidance
because it is an important decision we
could be about to make okay if you'd
like to clarify the issues particularly
around parking for us once more okay and
assessing its proposal its proposing
four parking spaces for two two-bedroom
flats and this is considered being a
pulse with the PO parking standards and
which I'm bound by an and have two by
two and they do measure the minimum two
point two point nine by five and whilst
you know concerns being raised around
size of car parking faces they do
compile the minimum car parking
dimensions and you know I do appreciate
that concern has been raised with
regards to loss of a car parking space a
visitor car parking spaces a space and I
mean looking at this development
assistance of our policy and our
guidance this this proposal compliance
with what's there whilst I appreciate
you talk about modern life and today and
I do I do appreciate that you know
the the policy and guidelines do state
that we do require two car parking
spaces per a two-bedroom plus dwelling
so this is in accordance with that and
hence why it has been recommended for
approval
thank you members there is a recommended
a point of order on that because that's
factually in council high that's
factually incorrect not I've got real
are members from this point on cancer
Stanley
are you telling me that the car parking
space is now on two point nine five is
thirty now a policy minimum in the car
parking standards do state the minimum
dimensions I can't tell you thank you
what page number on that but they are
there yes and they be copies at two
point five by five the minimum no that's
the minimum maximum two point nine by
five point five minimums two point five
by five five five five that's minimum
maximum is two point nine by five point
five and these these car parking spaces
comply with the minimum dimension
cuz that's our maximum car pop why is
that mr. Stanley well we're not
discussing to Stanley work we've got to
deal on factual issues that that that's
the fact we can't argue about the policy
at this point in time where were the
policies of policy we're implementing it
or or not as it's the case cancer Wilson
one last time I still don't believe that
we're compliant chairman because if
we're saying that we should have a
visitor space and notwithstanding the
fact that you might say you could argue
one way or the other I do think that we
should be exemplary in
adherence to her own policies and I
would move for refusal on the grounds
that we don't comply with policy DM 30
and notwithstanding what's in the report
about their bid no significant impact by
not having that visitors i've been up
there and it would have significant so I
would move refused it on those grounds
counts the Stanley would second that
right members does anyone want to speak
on the motion for refusal I would just
say as I as I did a few minutes ago this
is a very fine decision this is
effectively a visitor parking space and
it's for your members to take a decision
on on how much you you can you can put
on on the weight of that okay right
members on that do you want to just
restate it one final time for officers
benefit so as they can just note that
down yeah I'll move to refusal on the
grounds that we don't comply with their
own policy DM 30 in as much as that
there was no visitors parking space okay
thank you
and that's I can go back out to Stanley
those Maeve members in favor of the
refusal please indicate
I was against the refusal thank you that
item is refused thank you we come back
in councilor Merrick if any of our
visitors don't want to spend longer then
feel free to
Sonya's gonna forget
yeah
Sonia yeah yeah
okay
can I just ask the rest of our visitors
which item you're you're here for is it
item six barrel lane now
Alexandra Road yeah
Alexandra Road okay all right everyone
back okay with the committee's agreement
for our visitors benefit we'll move on
to item seven that okay that's where
most our visitors here for now okay
right item seven its land to the rear of
three to forty five Alexandra Road great
Wakering
[Music]
Thank You chairman
this application relates to land we are
free to 45 Aleksandr Road and the site
lies to the east of Aleksandr Road which
is the main residential street and
planning permission is being sought to
demolish number 39 a Alexander Street
and Erik 25 2 story residential
dwellings a layer of a road car parking
and landscaping on land behind aleksandr
road this access into the site would be
gained from alexander road generator
roof levels please and the site proposes
a housing mix a11 bed 11 two beds and 13
free bed dwellings of these eight of
these eight are proposed to be
affordable with one of these being a one
bed property for to bed properties and
free free bed properties these portable
units would be sited to northern and
southern end of the site the density
would equate ascetics dwellings per
hectare and the layout comprised
detached semi-detached and terrorists
two-story dwellings your dwelling has
has dormers in the front roof scape
which are strategically
strategically faced and around site
although the plots comprise two car
parking spaces and a visitor parking and
which have been provided the amount of
off street car parking space is measured
in a quarter dr. chalking standards all
their proposed about 25 dwellings would
achieve the minimum internal dimensions
of the nasty described space standards
all of the plots provide real amenity
space comply with the supplementary
planning document number 2 which is
housing design a sufficient space would
be provided to accommodate the necessary
storage requirements of each dwelling
within the rear gardens and the bins
provide and sorry the gardens the garden
proposal website access we have
exception of plot 15 which is a bin
store located to the rear of its parking
space due to property being middle
Terrace and it's considered that there
are sufficient distances between the
proposed dwellings and existing
residential property surround the site
it is considered that a development
and of this nature could be accommodated
within sight that would not result in
detrimental impact upon the occupiers of
neighboring properties by way of it
causing excessive overshadowing as a
result of being overbearing of cause
overlooking or lots of privacy and the
street scene illustrates the appearance
of the e/m scale Vulcan hire 25
dwellings and which I proposed and I
considered acceptable and it's
considered that design and character the
development respects the surrounding
area and provides a traditional built
form of contemporary elevational
treatments that will contribute to the
appearance of the area due to design
citing the proportions of development
there will be no me to impact upon the
living conditions of neighboring
residents and residents in relation to
overshadowing dominance are overlooked
in the the development would provide car
parking vision the calls to the car car
parking standards and would not be
detrimental to highway safety on this
basis and the proposal is considered to
meet quirements of development plan and
the MPP F and he's recommending approval
subject to the appropriate condition and
section 106 contributions thank you
thank you I have two speakers on this
one counts lachemann from
[Music]
five minutes young got a minute to go
good evening my name is Phil hitch Minh
from the great white creme Parish
Council we've had a couple of meetings
parish councils about this to which
residents were invited and we've had an
awful lot of strong objections to the
application mainly around Alexandra Road
itself rather than the development the
main objections were really access and
lack of parking spaces now that exam de
Road if anybody knows it knows that it's
always full up there are no parking
spaces left it's also used as a
overspill from the high street so and
because it's a long straight narrow road
cars tend to park up on the pavements
now this creates a number of problems
first of all putting a spine road in to
the new development would mean we're
going to lose a good number of parking
spaces particularly as it's quite narrow
and you need quite a sweep to get into
the road so we could be talking about
six to eight parking spaces lost in eggs
onto road alone there was also concern
especially the visibility coming in and
out of the new road again partly because
of the number of cars and vans at the
parked up on the the pavement the whole
time visibility coming out the road
would be reduced but be quite difficult
to get in and out of the road I would
think the road is very narrow we already
have a problem with service vehicles and
the emergency vehicles getting up and
down the road this is going to compound
the problem we feel it we also felt that
the proposed development was overcrowded
too many houses first such a small slice
of Lane I couldn't actually find any
reference to what the minimum actually
czaka dining for their efforts and
maximum which sounds a bit strange to me
but they're talking about 25
houses though dwellings awesome this
plot which we think is overdevelopment
there are also a few other concerns
regarding positioning of workers hearts
during the development we did request an
archaeological investigation before
works commenced because he's known to be
quite an old plot
it's also worth citing probably that
initially they thought it was a
brownfield site but it's not it's not
listed brownfield is actually a nursery
which is agricultural they're not belief
and I think that's about it thank you
very much
[Music]
hello again
okay the application is again gained
officer support the NPP F encourages
effective use of lands to provide
much-needed housing the officer stated
in principal development of this site is
appropriate to deliver such housing the
proposal is for two-story house in with
some limited rooms in the roof space
providing a varied mix of type size and
tenure density of 36 dwellings per
hectare which sits well within policy
and is comparable to other developments
in the area the design of the properties
has taken direct influence from the
surrounding properties with a more
contemporary approach within the
traditional forms and proportions seen
in and around the high street and has
received positive comments from the
local authorities open designer one of
the biggest concerns raised by residents
during the planning consultation period
was the inadequacy of Alexandra Road in
terms of capacity and parking we have a
robust report from our highways
consultant as well as correspondents
from Essex highways confirming that the
road is adequate and the proposed
parking is acceptable and fully policy
compliant with sufficient allocated
parking and seven dedicated visitor
spaces throughout the site the new spine
Road provides the opportunity of a
hundred plus metres of road for
overspill on street parking negating any
further pressures on eggs onto Road
itself so whilst there is a turning had
been created we are creating 100 metres
of new road that people could park on
all the rear garden amenity spaces are
fully compliant with planning policy and
the layout and orientation of the
properties has been carefully designed
to minimise overlooked in to existing
residents again fully compliant in
separation distance a comprehensive
intech integrated landscaping design
also accompanies the application provide
in a net gain of over 40 trees across
the site it is noted within the offices
report that the proposals are not
considered to have a detrimental impact
upon the private amenity of the
occupiers of the existing properties in
relation to having an overbearing or
overlooking impact
a concern was raised by the adjacent
neighbor guarding the sighting of the
enclosed substation building and the
plans under consideration are the
updated version following an agreement
on site to move the building further
away from the boundary line and provide
a planting buffer so in summary the site
provides an excellent opportunity to
provide an officer supported scheme
fully policy compliant delivering 25
well-designed thought-through homes
sympathetic and unique to their
immediate surroundings and neighbors and
great Waker in itself I also like to
point out the brownfield is a term that
means this site has been used before so
agricultural and brownfield are two
completely separate zones thank you
thank you
all right our non-members first council
Macpherson's that indicated and council
stepped out Thank You chairman okay
first of all I'd like to draw the
committee two errors in the report my
compliments have to go to my eagle-eyed
Co ward councillor for noticing list one
if you have a look on page seven point
two six four point two two you'll see
the report from the south essex parking
partnership who basically give their
okay to this and who they refer to it in
relation to Helena Road which is in
railing so one do they actually realize
this application is in great Wakering
and what are their comments in relation
to its the parking okay or not because
we don't know now do we I also refer you
to page seven point two to three point
seven seven this is regarding the
provision of open space and play space
the report says in our quote or read
from it with Burroughs park and
Plainfield located so close to the site
he's not considered that the lack of
open and play space for public use
directly will directly impact on the
application site would be objectionable
here can I point out to the committee
that borough Pharaohs Park which is
quoted in this report it's not a public
park it's not a public playing field he
is actually a privately run Football
Club so not accessible to the public
except of course on match days when they
want to watch the football so based on
those errors I don't know how many more
there are in this report that others may
have found but you may want to consider
deferring this item
I then refer to page 7.3 under
conditions the fourth bullet point seven
point four number eight seven point five
number eleven these are all the sort of
basic conditions that you expect of any
developer not to do anything before the
application is put in
unfortunately this developer had already
demolished any existing buildings and
cleared the site of all buildings trees
wildlife and habitation before they even
put in this application so if the
developer had no regard before will they
in the future I would have thought
perhaps remedial reports on ecological
archaeological studies need to take
place and should have been presented
alongside this application as mentioned
Alexandra Road has already got parking
at full capacity so this development
would not only impact on the residents
by taking away a proportion of their
parking we also also create more
difficulties with the overspill from
this development
however I've just made a note that the
agent says the hundred metres of new
road to park on is not mentioned in this
report and if so perhaps this could be a
condition this is made available for the
local residents and if so officers need
to check the width of the road to make
sure that such vehicles as heavy goods
vehicles lorries dust carts can also get
down there with parking
there's huge safety concerns over the
entrance and exit I can appreciate what
the agent has just said but we're war
counselors we live there we know what
this road is like displays will not
provide enough visibility and how will a
refuse vehicle or similar let alone the
works traffic for this site get in and
out in my opinion it's over development
there's too many homes squeezed into
this plot of course the developer will
be wanting to squeeze as much money out
of the development but not to the
detriment of our residents thank you
very much it was suggested in a meeting
with officers that this was put to the
developer to consider less homes more
parking unless there was no response
from this developer all opportunity to
discuss this further lastly and perhaps
officers can answer this do all the room
sizes and dimensions comply with our
policies and if not why not as it's been
said earlier there's little point in
having policies if we do not ensure
developers comply with them Thank You
general that's the Steptoe thank
chairman first of all as it has been
mentioned I ought to declare an interest
because I am the chairman of southeast
Essex parking partnership just to
clarify that as a point chairman I have
two questions which I'd like office to
answer first and it depends on their
that's a visiting member you can you can
make you stay on them but you can
interact little brains right okay with
regards to the status of the land I
believe that it is Greenbelt there has
been recently a test case in other parts
of the country particularly around glass
houses and green houses that they are
not pre development land and they are
not brownfield we recently had a test a
case here with in Rockford in
Stonebridge which is a similar site
which had a number of rogue class
is on and it was refused
on that basis because it was green belt
not pre-developed and not brown field so
the fact that it's green filled green
belt I would like to know what special
circumstances have been put forward to
actually allow this development the
speaker mentioned about the maximum
number of buildings in the in a given
area I think we refer to it as density
so I'd like to see some clarification on
whether this actually meets the density
requirements of our policy I think that
may be what the speaker was trying to
refer to thanks Jim mrs. Holly but I
always think we never seen financial
contribution to all secretary transform
provisions but that's not gonna be any
good if there isn't any schools for them
to go to thank you know the non-members
wish to say anything
oh sorry counsel mr. Howe as well
Thank You chairman I'm just briefly on
the affordable housing I'll make you 32
percent not our minimum 35 percent I
know there's rounding involved I thought
we'd nobody ran it up knock down if that
could be clarified I'd be grateful
understand he's not a question with
regard to the parking it does meet the
standard however I point out that the
policy is not a maximum of 2.9 by 5.5 is
a preferred 2.9 by 5.5 it's not a
maximum thank you just before we go to
member Sam would you like to sort of
inform the debate with reference to four
point two to three point seven seven
states to the land density and
the rounding or not of the affordable
I'll start with room sizes which you
asked question on this development does
comply with the national housing space
standards which sets out room sizes and
internal dimensions of a dwelling and I
confirmed that this development does
comply with that and moving on to a it
is phrased at sites Greenbelt according
to a local a proposals map this site
isn't in Greenbelt is just outside the
Greenbelt and I mean you're right say
it's not brownfield it has been classed
as brownfield and it hasn't been classed
as a PDL iPhone and as you say we've had
a test case recently it refers to glass
house he's not being on PDL and yeah
you're right national playing policy
framework does say that any agricultural
land or nursery excetera
should not be PTO and they start hasn't
the classes P do density our policy
states minimum 30 dwellings and this is
36 and is compliant we've ever developed
that's been allowed in the area and of
our allocation sites and affordable
housing and was mentioned this does
comply of our policy and he's 35 percent
so it is complying but eight units
[Music]
everything they parked at parking
partnership oh yes and yes I get
Connelly pointed out to me about the
surface its parking partnership earlier
and I did consult with him we s as an
authority we have to consult with the
highway 40 ethics in this instance I did
go beyond that and consult with Essex
parking partnership so this isn't a
standard thing that we do for all
applications it was just that an issue
was raised to me and in my email did
state the application number and the
address and great whickering and the
officer came back with this response and
I believe that hill in the road doesn't
exist in great way Kareem and however it
was made clear to the officer at Essex
that it was great Wakering and they may
have refer to another site but like I
say this consultation is going above and
beyond what we generally do and who we
consult so please bear that in mind
they've been not the determining forty
when it comes to car parking thank you
okay thank you
that's our F T
don't need to stand I'm sorry
okay thank you chairman I'll actually I
think they should go to a deferment
actually as the report with the yetis
parking partnership is incorrect and it
was based on a false premise as it's
actually an exam to Riley and I don't be
any doubt in what's actually we're
voting on your soul
using me porks are not actually relevant
to the site where we're talking about I
think he's not good so I'd actually like
to propose that you Furman I you you can
put that afford it it's not not anything
I would support because they are not a
statutory consultation area but but it's
over and above and the the formal
statutory consultation there have
referred to the right places it's not
it's not something I could defer I agree
with as a deferment cancer Stanley
always sorry
I've always thought that the developer
or whoever e's should have a change of
use to that whether it's be grass glass
house or or nursery or whatever as a
change of use I always thought that that
was the first and foremost thing that
they would do and then getting from that
as you very well know I do like a bit of
flooding I do and this is scepter ball
to flooding and I wonder if the planes
have been put in or put to you to to
rectify or to mediate this this the
problem that they may have there if I
can I can straight away point you to
looking for it I recommend a the
recommendation on on seven point two the
the reason for and then the read the
reasons that go with it and it's
specifically mentions to prevent
flooding by ensuring satisfactory
storage of disposal of surface water
from the site and so on yes about
halfway down seven point three yes our
question fully I'm see what what you're
aiming for it's just that it's really
concerning that adequate I know it says
forty percent plus forty percent storage
of whatever you but are we happy with
with that proposal in in in the flooding
agenda
and yeah the site falls in flood zone
one so it's low probability of flooding
and drainage urban that's sustainable
urban drainage has strategy has been put
to us and that has been assessed by
Essex County Council the lead local
flood authority who raised no objections
to what's being proposed and we are
happy with what is being proposed and
when conditions have been recommended to
on this application for further
informations coming regarding sort of
maintenance logs and other things but
yeah generally we are happy with what is
being proposed part of this development
like I say it has been assessed by the
Lea local flood authority who are
satisfied with the proposal that was put
forward and so therefore a couple of
points of clarification
one is that council McPherson said that
work had already started on demolition
do you know if that's the case I believe
that to be the case that works had
commenced prior to an application being
put forward to the council to demolish
and the glass houses as well as sort
clearing of the site or see if there
isn't anything in you know they didn't
require permission to do so and
obviously I appreciate least it upset a
lot of residents in the local area
because of ecology issues and stuff like
that however ecology reports work into
the council to consider and but work did
commenced prior to an application coming
in clearing off the site but like I say
we have no control of their over that as
planning permission wouldn't necessary
be required for such it works that's
within the site then okay the second
question I've got and again it follows
on from council McPherson and it's to do
open space and play space and it's on
page 7.2 to paragraph 3.77 and it's only
our policy seal t5 and CL t7
open space and place possibly provided
in new residential developments but it
goes on into say that some space is
proposed but this would be private space
so we sign that this private space
actually isn't usable as public open
space no public open space is being
proposed within the development itself I
mean it's quite a small parcel of land
and so incorporates all play space would
be quite difficult and and it was
considered that they read local parks in
the nearby vicinity I appreciate you
said that I've got and named the park
wrong but I was informed that was the
name and and we can look at that but and
because of local nearby parks and other
open recreational spaces and 11 an area
of open space for play equipment except
you wouldn't necessarily required in
this incident I know for a fact that
some of the records that suds have got
the Essex are not quite up to up to
staying up to date teenager fact and I
just questioned that although we accept
their dealings on what they consider we
accept it I do think that perhaps we
should enquire a little bit more as to
they are right not just to accept my
position is it as you may know that
where I am we drawer if and what's going
on vacations we accept things on the
basis of we haven't played there
ourselves so you know I've just question
that I mean members we have a
recommendation for approval printed on
seven-point-one going through there's
some issues some details with regard to
the section one
six agreement to be determined we've had
the recommendation from officers that
this is a fair and compliance scheme so
I'll take this one to the boat those
members in favor of the approval please
indicate those against
that's 5h so just just again plays one
two three four five six and five right
okay
that item is not approved not approved
doesn't mean it's refused so I now come
to members to ask for someone to take
the debate forward which would be a
motion for refusal councillor Stanley
you've indicated thank you but the the
other going there go in there thank you
this is purely of what we've said here
is that the the we're talking about
spaces for four so you know as an open
space play space and open spaces and
there isn't any been put forward by the
officers and there's nothing on site for
a community or anything like that and
that's the reason for my refusal thank
you
lack of lack of play space is quite a
week a week reason for refusal in my
opinion on a building development of
this size councillor that just sent the
councillors sure has just indicated as
well she did she comes roughly
okay so we've we've had a motion to
defer and second can I just ask for the
clarity for officers and to allow the
the applicant full information to have
the particular issues that are of
concern and that of course the the
application not to be passed tonight
that's our F D status of the land right
yep two E's open spaces the open space
it's got no contribution when I was six
money now that we found out it's not
phased private loans it's not public
land yeah also the report Phineas's
clarified so that's three point seven
seven there's roughly one small
ecological reports as well I think I
need to be well okay so thank you
so your content that you've got enough
information to continue a dialogue with
the applicant to allow members to come
back and discuss it with a bit more
information and make a make a final
decision on one or the other in future
okay so I just have members just
formally indicate in favor of the
deferral and he against the deferral
that item is deferred then you can may I
just asked a question if the company are
doing something with the land already
clear or whatever cannot be stopped
until we have covered this many many
times our training sessions the whole
development could be constructed but
it's done at risk it's done at risk
right so that item seven was deferred if
any of our visitors this evening wish to
go now feel free and what we'll be
moving on to item six next which is land
to the west of little Wakering Road and
south of Barrow home road little
Wakering there is an agenda some
addendum information on that one as well
we arrange the ball
I'm sorry
okay chairman miss is a reserved matters
application for the proposed development
of 120 dwellings land west of little
Oakland Road and south of Belleville
Road in little way cream in association
with an outline application approved
this site in 2017 the site consists of
open land bordered by residential
dwellings in little working modes down
here and then we've got town field walk
and old school meadow in this location
as well
this application seeks approval of the
appearance landscaping layout and scale
of the development it should be noted
that the outline application is the
overarching decision which looked at
matters relating to surface water
drainage highway implications
construction management and 106
contributions name but a few
it is not for the application currently
before us to revisit those matters as
part of the outline many of which are
controlled by conditions which you
impose on the outline application the
main access to the site from bearable
Road was part of the outline application
but subject to conditions which required
discharge as referred to in the
officer's report the main access to the
site is not for determination here
within this application the red line
shows the site boundary that we're
looking at the mix of the proposed 120
dwellings would be as follows we're
looking at 10 one beds 28 to beds 53 and
32 for beds the proposal also
incorporates internal roads we've got an
amenity area along this side here which
has to play spaces within it and a
surface water drainage pond located here
and a pumping station just to the south
here so the key material planning
considerations are parking appearance
landscaping layout and scale we regards
to parking the resident parking space
numbers and cycle parking provision is
adhere to the apartment plot amazing
Nets provide a cycle store for their
residents and visitors with a
requirement to expand the size to enable
little more visitor parking in the
future so they are to the southern end
here that's the apartment block located
there and the major nets are here the
number of visitor parking spaces meets
the requirements with some additional on
plot spaces also provided power to
wheeler and disabled Bay provision is
here
to the parking Bay Anchorage sizes are
also met along with the six meter
reversing distances County highways have
raised concern regarding some plots
which have some additional space to
their drivers that might encourage
parking over the foot way a condition
has been imposed to address this we look
at plan three Oh lovely thank you so the
site uses five character areas we're
looking at a boulevard squares lanes and
courts of green fingers and a rural edge
so this just shows the street scene here
is the barrel hill road frontage that we
would be looking at as you can see
there's a they're mostly traditional
style and form properties but with some
contemporary design features
particularly the use and location of
fenestration there are 31 different
house types although most of variations
are three key house types the report
does refer to 28 actually however 31 and
our proposed due to slight amendment to
the full rent mix unit unit mix this is
just showing you what the apartment
block would look like so again we're
looking at quite sort of traditional
forms but with a contemporary sort of
look and feel to the design the proposed
materials comprised red Luton gray
plumbing buff brickwork we thorough
colored through colored off-white render
and dark red plain and gray slate effect
tiles County urban designed an object to
the proposal following revisions which
have taken place during the course of
the scheme with regards to landscaping
there's various soft and hard
landscaping post across the site new
trees with mostly line the roadways and
be within the open space with shrubs and
perennials mostly focused around the
front garden areas and prominent visual
areas boundary treatment would include
brick wall into visible boundary edges
the council's are vocalist is not
objects condition 23 of the approved
outlined application would agree the
full landscaping requirements just
looking at the layout now so the density
is 22 point for dwellings per hectare
that is below our minimum 30 which we
seek by policy but it's considered
appropriate for the site context and
that policy does allow us a degree of
flexibility looking at the site and
character of an area with the dwelling
mix we're looking at between one to four
bed units so we've got a good mix of
dwellings within the site one metre
separate
around 2100 aliens that don't meet the
one-metre criteria however these still
provide the visual gaps that we would
seek through green space access ways or
parking areas and that loan is not
considered a reason for refusal here
with regards to residential amenity
that's not considered to be a
detrimental impact on existing
neighboring darlings there are 12
instances where the 25 meter and 15
meter separation distances are not
provided however in the relationships is
still considered acceptable the
technical housing standards are met
across the sites and we have for we all
share accessible units which have been
identified which you again are in
accordance with our policy the garden
areas for all plots meet our policy
requirements there are two plots
referred to in the report as below
standard but the agent has alerted
officers to additional areas within
these parts which actually hadn't been
included in the original calculations so
it can be confirmed that the amenities
and for those for those plots they'll
now adhere to with regards to refuse a
refuse vehicle could track through the
development bin story to be within rear
gardens and the apartment block amazing
it's would have communal stores refuse
arrangements including drag distances
are also considered acceptable five
thank you this is just another street
scene this is actually the boulevard
looking throwing straight down the site
as you would drive in so the building
height suppose a predominantly two-story
and under 9 meters width apart and block
measuring around nine point one and two
house types at ten point three so you
can see some of the difference in the
house Heights along here so this would
be the ten point three version you'd
have sort of barriers up and down sort
of designs and that's considered
acceptable variety across the site
moving on just some other matters the
open space and play space the quantity
shown for both open and play space it
heads to the allocations plan we're
looking at a formal housing the proposal
seeks a slight amendment to the
affordable rented unit mix but this is
still in accordance with the council's
35% requirement and it's in accordance
with the council strategic housing team
aren't they consider to be the need is
for the Rockford area looking at youth
and community facilities a twenty five
thousand pound
Lucian is sought towards a multi-use
games area a great way Korean open space
and that has been agreed and accepted by
the developer and we've lost ecology the
council have conducted a further
appropriate assessment as part of the
habitat regulation since the outline
application was undertaken this is
concluded that the mitigation should be
saw equating to fourteen thousand six
hundred and seventy six pounds and that
has been accepted by the applicant
chairman this application is recommended
for approval subject to conditions thank
you thank you have a speaker on this
grievance members issue will be aware
the site to benefits from outlined plan
admission for 120 new houses with public
open space parking and associated
development this reserve matters plan
application is pursuant to such details
relating to matters of appearance
landscaping layout and scale only in
addition the site is allocated for new
who will with residential development
within the council's of adopted
allocations plan since the submission of
this detailed application in it November
2018 the applicant sanctuary homes has
remained committed to work in and
collaboratively with officers to ensure
full support for these that for these
detail proposals can be achieved in line
with key local development plan and MPP
F principles as members will have
recently seen at the applicant had
provided a significant standard of
detail in support of this application
including a number of comprehensive and
detailed further as submissions in
response to officer an urban design
feedback this has assisted in the
positive officer recommendation of
approval now being achieved
the proposal has sought to provide a
varied mix of housing across the site
which includes 31 separate house types
predominantly through variations of
freaky house types as well as an
apartment block and some and Mason it's
the layout of the proposal seeks to
build on the aspirations of the outlined
Planning Commission in focusing new
development to the east of the site with
a significant green lung to the site
Western extent to provide an appropriate
transition to the wider at Greenbelt
land as well as incorporating
high-quality public open space this is
important as it improves the the
pedestrian links across the site as well
as incorporating the drainage features
and to children's play areas the layout
of the development of the East has also
been carefully planned to complement
this green area including high quality
views to and from it from within the
site itself and free the distinctive
green lungs that run east to west
through the site's improving overall
accessibility in and around it a set out
within the officers report the outline
plan of mission does not put a limit on
the overall height of buildings
notwithstanding this the heights
proposed are predominately two-story in
nature to maintain a largely true story
character across the site in addition
there are some larger house types which
would be located at roti checkpoints
within the development to achieved focal
points which is again fully supported by
officers as illustrated by the layout of
the development proposed soft
landscaping soft landscaping proposals
or sin are essential feature of the
development and are incorporated across
its extent this includes in relation to
public open space green lungs and the
frontage of the site with Borough Hall
Road as made clear within the officers
report the matter of access is not a
relevant material consideration in the
determination of this planning
applications as such details were
approved as part of the outline of
planning application and were not
reserved
however the following access concerns
being raised to the applicant
part of this process they have responded
that positively in engaging the highway
consultant to reconsider the site's
access a detailed highways report was
subsequently prepared and circulated to
officers and concluded that the existing
approved access on Tobacco Road is the
best access option for the site
importantly this continues to be
supported by the highway authority as
such the applicant does not propose to
revisit this approved matter this
approve matter so given its overall
level of acceptability as members will
note they signed at the section 106
agreement is attached to be associated
outlined plan information which includes
clauses in respect of affordable housing
highways health care and education in
addition the applicant has agreed to
further 106 clauses in respect of a
contribution towards the local youth and
community provision and the mitigation
immolations HRA are set out within
officers committee report these include
additional
additional benefits not currently
secured by the outline Planning
Commission in addition the applicant
would like to make aware that there are
no outstanding objections to this
planning application from statutory
console T's and although there have been
some neighbor objections these have been
fully addressed within the offices
planning committee report in conclusion
the detailed proposals would represent a
sustainable form of development
supported by the local development plan
and MPP F and will be of a high quality
design and layout
therefore the proposals constitute
sustainable development and as such
members are urged to support this
proposal and go on detailed planning
commission accordingly thank you very
much Thank You members first and you've
indicated Thank You chairman just before
I get begin I want to give thanks to
both Sarah Bryant and Chris Cole from
sanctuary housing who I have to say
they've engaged with ward councillors
from the outset included meeting with us
I will be speaking on just the proposal
to discharge condition 45 the outlined
application for this site was approved
with condition 45 please could I urge
members of the Development Committee to
note this if you refer to page 6.4 311
for your paperwork now read from their
developer to reassess the access site
and to submit details to the local
planning authority of adjustments to be
made to deter vehicles from turning left
into barrel Road which should be
approved by local planning authority and
in consultation with the ward members
and then note the reason in the
interests of Road Safety so why was this
condition put forward the simple answer
is because the ward members know their
ward and they know better than this
highways that's for sure so I've got an
email here from the I seen from I see
neither then does that just design off
the site it's addressed to the officer
at Essex highways thank you for taking
time to meet me today to discuss the
great weight green site as mentioned in
accordance with councilor wishes we have
been tasked we provided an acceptable
designed to deter residents from
arriving in departing via barrel Hall
Road good so far then there's a next bit
it is however noted there Essex County
Council do not support any of the
schemes which are believed to be
unnecessary inappropriate and very from
an additional street clutter to
potentially dangerous situations so
they've got total disregard of the
condition that was put forward by
councillors of this committee I've got a
further email from the officer Essex
County Council
and he says I have reviewed the
additional information related to the
access Arrangements and the land of our
haul road Undertaker by David Tucker
Associates I believe this is a report
that you referred to that was
commissioned by the Highways report
I want the majority of vehicle movements
from this site will travel a long barrel
road and had seven leader direction
towards south end there is no highway
reason policy or technical to restrict
turning their turning movements from the
sides therefore the position of the
Highway Authority remains the same and
that the proposed junction is available
shall be provided to permit all turning
movements and the highway authority
agrees with the finding of the report
this report again since Tillery just one
paragraph in this reform
he says the route is perfectly adequate
to accommodate additional flows is
generally at least four point five
meters note that please committee and
therefore capable of accommodating to
wake our movements
existing flows are low and therefore the
cognitive impact would be modest there
is thus no justification the terms of
the MV P F test to restricting
additional vehicle movements along that
route so mmm according to Essex highways
the majority is the people who will exit
Bauer Hall Road will go eastwards
towards South End oh how does he know
this has Essex highways now employed
clairvoyants as well Essex highways have
reviewed the excess arrangements
undertaken by David Tasker associations
often said to report and the report is
wrong so as highways made their
assessment on guesswork and flawed
reports looks like it
I personally expect better for my
residence and I'm sure the other
councillors here do as well now I will
bring you back to the original reason
for adding condition 45 it was in the
interest of road safety
could I have my pictures up if that's
all right thank you
because as they say a picture can say a
thousand words and it happened
a few of them so here we're measuring a
road there's one of the widest parts of
the roads and it's four point ten meters
wide if we can go on to the next picture
if that's okay
it's fine like that but after Gifford
you can see it's just now here's a photo
at the same place of an oncoming volvo
transit lorry at this part of the road
on this vehicle specifications easy to
look at Google's wonderful it is two
thousand four hundred ninety millimeters
this does not include the wing mirrors
though but to be fair they would be
above most traffic this is one of the
wider parts of the road leaving this
lease a passing distance remember the
report said two cars can pass easily
Lisa passing distance of 1.6 meters now
I'll be honest I own a smart car
and this width it's not even enough for
me to get through next picture please
here again it's four point ten meters
note in the back there's a line of trees
just pass that blue car so we can go on
to the next picture that's the car in a
ditch quite quite a common event around
there we have a look at the next one if
you can notice there car park by the
Chevron say several Chevron's there to
tell everybody it's a sharp bend we
could have a look at the next one please
oh those Chevron's are no longer there
because they're under the van that is
pulled over to let somebody past and
gone into them if we can never look at
the next one and the next one all
different vehicles plowing through the
corner of that stretch of the road next
one please
and again the next one now this point
we're getting down to three point nine
five meters wide we can have a look at
the next one please we've got two Lori's
took them a little while so you can
mention everybody's sitting behind there
and the next one that's what happened to
one of the lorries and if we'd have a
look at the next one place different
lorry don't think it's the same lorry
similar position but look at the
proximity around those electricity
cables and poles might not be a
high-waist concern but is to me if my
residents don't have electricity so to
give you some idea if we go to just the
next one this is one of the most narrow
parts the road you'll see there's a
sharp bend as well there is no where to
pull in round there because one side
you've got hedgerow the other side
you've got people's houses gardens and
as you can see there a wall so to give
you some spatial awareness the top four
most popular cars in 2019 are for Fiesta
Ford Focus Volkswagen Golf and listen
cash guy if you drive one of these and
met each other coming the other way you
will not be able to pass there oh except
for the Volkswagen Golf back you would
be able to because all you need to do is
stop get out for the wing mirrors in get
back in and you can't get past that way
okay all of those pictures so far we're
taking during the nice weather if we can
just move on and next picture I just
want to give people an idea of what
we're dealing with here okay and on and
if you just go forward and just go keep
going and where there's a dead chicken
sorry but he got run over as we're in
the field and there's that he's a school
bus in the ditch so
as we all know Essex highways will be
seen by the Secretary of State as the
expert body however we've already spoken
today about challenging highway simply
and it's my understanding from the
development training sessions that we
have that we can challenge any experts
decision if it's based on sound evidence
based on the fact that highways have
supported and already proved flawed
report use their clairvoyant skills to
dictate which way the residents will
exit bear a whole Road from these photos
you decide if section 45 should be
removed or should this be deferred to
give Essex highways the opportunity to
present a road safety scheme such things
as pulling points to be able to give way
to oncoming traffic or build-outs
also to look at the restriction of heavy
goods vehicles and some simple traffic
calming message measures which can all
make a difference to the safety of our
residents just a reminder that we are
the elected representatives of Rochester
District Council elected by arrest
residents who put their trust into us
that we will endeavour to do to the best
of our ability to represent them
we the elected watcher district
councillors have something that Essex
highways do not have we have local
knowledge and we will be doing our
residents a disservice if we do not
present that local knowledge when
developments like this are put before us
without the infrastructure to support it
so in short I hate to say it but I think
it's time we put on our big-boy pants
and actually start to challenge Essex
highways when they make such
outstandingly poor decisions Thank You
council Steptoe Thank You chairman I'd
like to reinforce everything that
council and business said
at the committee meeting where we heard
for the outline application it was
something that I asked to be put on
there was condition what is now
condition 45 there is a president within
the area we have in Bali we have the
bowling tip which has a considerable
number of lorries and trucks that go
crossed
now they cross every one of those roads
South Ian's Road bowling road and Barrow
Hall Road the traffic that crosses there
is deferred from crossing and turning
into Borough Hall Road if they if the
county felt that they could use that
road why have they done that I see no
reason why that should be changed and
I'd also like clarification because my
understanding is that when a condition
is placed upon a planning application to
have that removed that has to come back
before the committee so how is it the
county can just simply ignore it I don't
believe that they can so therefore I
would stand shoulder shoulder with
Council of McPherson on this particular
point barrel whole Road is not suitable
for the amount of traffic that they're
suggesting in particular the
construction traffic that is likely to
come in certainly coming from from the
easterly direction and that the entrance
to the site is is in the wrong place it
should be in a completely different
place and I think there are options that
can be done they are more expensive I'll
accept that but I don't think we need to
be concerned about the cost of these
various things so I would stand by the
the condition that I had put upon the
previous application to put condition 45
and see no reason why that should not be
meant should be not be met and that the
traffic is
made to turn as it comes out of the site
on the drawing would be to the right or
in a westerly direction it's the only
way that that traffic can fly even that
is particularly tight thanks Jim thank
you my remembers just Dre did you want
to contribute to this one members just
before we move on accounts limit first
and backed up by accounts to step to
have have made particularly passionate
points with regards to highways but I
think the officers need to address you
and give you some clear guidance about
the application that's in front of us
tonight just to explain with regards to
the access it's not for consideration as
part of this particular application it
was something that was addressed within
the outline application we have got this
condition 45 which does need to be
addressed in some way so if the
developer is not looking to comply with
that condition then they will need to
apply to the council to vary or remove
that condition and it is at that point
that we can then discuss and get into
the realms of the access arrangement but
this application is a reserved matters
for the outline and we consider to the
access Arrangements on the outline
application and they were determined at
that poem subject to those conditions
and it's not for this application to
reach a decision or view on the access
arrangement on two-barrel whole Road as
part of this application we're looking
at appearance landscaping layout and
scale specifically okay cancer FD
subject to condition 45 so that has not
been taken in consideration in this
application so you said you lay out the
print the principle of the highway
access is determined the detail of how
of how it will be arranged is through
another mechanism and not what we're
talking about tonight right so that
would still be in place even if we
decide tonight
so if whatever you decide tonight they
were still need to address this
condition so if they're looking to
remove or vary it either they're not
looking to if they're not looking to
comply with that condition there we need
to have make an application to very
we'll remove that condition and it's at
that point as it was a councillor
imposed condition as well we would bring
it back to Development Committee for
consideration and discussion at that
point sure Thank You chair I page six
point to item number thirteen the
condition disabled mr. BAE's outside
plot fourteen to be changed visitor
which I have actually passed over the
question the quick the answer come back
from yourself was there would be one
visit abate with this disabled standard
if this condition was applied rather
than the three spaces that technically
would be required Essex County Council
highways consider these two spaces are
not needed why if we need three spaces
for this development for disabled people
why are we only allowing one to be thank
you so that the three spaces is what
complies with the parking stand
requirement so that's the technical
calculation and for that County highways
have come back and said that they're not
particularly in favor of the two that
are directly opposite before and plot
for I'll just show you it from the
distance is is this one here so the two
plots of it the two spaces we're talking
about a roundabout here and they haven't
given a specific reason but I'm thinking
that maybe it's along the lines of
people actually using the open space and
perhaps they're thinking that they would
be better served as
visitor buys rather than putting them as
disabled bays but I personally don't
have any particular issue if we were to
not impose that condition because it
does still comply with our parking
standards if we are requesting the three
versus what can t Horace have sort yes
we could remove we don't need to push
ahead with that condition if councillors
and not particularly in favor of it it's
advice and guidance and County highways
on how they think that site would work
best with regard to disable base Thank
You chairman I'm quite happy to support
this proposal however as a committee I
think we would be negligent in not
taking into account the evidence put
before us by councillor McPherson as
long as that can be addressed at a later
stage I'm quite happy just all this
cancer Stanley Thank You chairman the
condition 45 would really alter the if
you like the entrance to the whole plan
and how could we how could we pass this
this this plan if condition 45 would
actually mean that the entrance to the
site would be somewhere else could you
give some notification on that if the
entrance to the site were to be someone
else that would be a fundamental change
to the application and the whole
application would come back to us
because the principle of access at that
point is is is approved we're looking at
the reserved matters we're looking at
the reserved matters as stated in the
application with regard to appearance
landscaping and parking
I understand what you mean it feels a
bit backwards yeah but it's potentially
yes if if it was the case that there was
an issue of that access and we weren't
to agree to very remove that condition
then yes it would it may require a
redesign of the scheme and then we'd be
looking at another reserved matters or
another full application coming in at
that particular point we were charged
with determining this application that's
in front of us tonight it's a decision
you all come to Casa Wilson thank
chairman I said just a question really
on them page 620 paragraph 410 Essex
County Council urban design they make
the policy of comment which I agree with
actually about the large amount of soft
landscaping but they ask a question
which is about the attenuation feature
and it says is it a basin which will
hold standing water for a considerable
amount of time if so will it be fenced
and the reason I'm asking is because if
it's fence in effect the amount of
usable public open space is reduced
we I can't specifically answer whether
it's going to be fenced or not as part
of this application because I don't we
don't have that level of detail right
now but it is something again the
outline application had conditions
attached with regards to landscaping
which also dealt with a degree of
boundary treatment so it would be within
those conditions that we'd be looking at
that but yes I suppose if it is fenced
it would it may limit to the usage of
that area as open space there is that
potential answer after you wanted to
come back again
larger than two-story buildings on there
for me yes I could show you these so
they therefore the and sorry the
apartment block is located here and that
is the the largest on the on the site
and we do have various actual house
types as well I think there's there's
two house types that are those greater
heights too and there they're put in
relatively prominent positions to make
give them a bit of visual impact and
they are entrances of the site but the
the the key main one of the high is this
one here and as well as say some of the
odd house types dotted throughout the
scheme through the chair again will the
windows be missed it over so no
overlooking because where they put that
I've looking houses and they'll get
there's no condition suggested because
that hasn't been looked at as part of
the application so within the
application process we consider where
all the windows are positioned
particularly in relation to existing
dwellings and if considered of necessary
we impose conditions requiring and those
be obscure glazed but when looked at
this apartment block location actually
they have the developer has actually
considered the usage of some of those
windows on that side and so they are
mostly of use that she's not going to
generate a great degree of overlooking
and also there's going to be a soft
landscape you can't see because we're a
bit far away here in a minute but
there's going to be a soft landscape
four along this edge which would also
help prevent overlooked in as well Thank
You Lucas kale
Thank You German refer to page six point
two to item four point two five and item
eight four point two five [ __ ] very
steep and this is out of keeping with
the surrounding area four point two
eight this house type needs a revision
or removing I cannot see anything in the
rest of the papers answering that and so
this is referring to the Essex County
urban design first response comment is
that correct what happened so we had
various design put we had the original
design put in County design made that
initial comment we then had them make
changes in light of particularly County
urban zoning other issues and they came
back and made revisions and County
design have now we've looked at it and
they are now happy with what they are
seeing in terms of design on the scheme
so they feel that their initial concerns
and that were raised within that
particular comment have been addressed
but yes so during the course of the
application there was changes which
resulted in a recon sille tation because
this applications has been in a while
with us and as a result of county urban
design comments they made a lot of
changes and revisions and county urban
zoning out in support of the scheme so
just before we we move on to the
decision members have made clear that
there there is significant concern about
the way in which condition forty five is
discharged and although not for
determination tonight you'll just
reassure members that you've heard those
points and and and issues raised that
loud and clear thank you so the
recommendation for approval is printed
on six point one on the matter
on the matters on this particular
application you can have those members
in favor of the approval please indicate
those against that item is approved
thank you right our next one is item
nine land to the rear of one to eight
sound Lane its we should we should get
through this item in less than half an
hour but before I start it can have
members agreement that we complete this
item within tonight's meeting just in
case it drags on well I will start with
this item wasn't
so item 9 1 is a referred application
from the weekly list land to the rear of
1 to 8 style lane Rayleigh construction
of 2 three-bedroom bungalow so chairman
this is an application for the
construction of 2 bungalows to the rear
of 1 to 8 style lane in Rayleigh the
site is a t-shaped area of land as you
can see here with a narrow frontage onto
style Lane this spot here between
numbers 3 & 5 the site has been used for
many years as residential garden to
number 5 star Lane style Lane is an
unmade Road which runs along the
southeastern boundary of King George's
playing field on the edge of Rayleigh
Town Center so as you can see here this
is the huge orgeous playing field you've
got a play area here and you've got ball
lane coming around here the character of
the areas residential nasai is also
bordered by garden boundaries of
dwellings in Queens Road along here and
Meadow side here the proposal is for the
construction of two three-bedroom
bungalow facing each other with a
centrally positioned
parking in turn the area access for
beaver eye style Lane the bungles would
have hipped roof forms in design so this
one's got as you can see and the hip
style here and quite a prediction look
if we can move to Planet sorry thank you
and again we're looking at a hip
designed property with a bit more of an
unusual roof form so the key material
planning considerations are the
appropriateness of infill development
environmental sustainability ecology and
flood risk so with regards to
appropriateness the proposed development
would not reflect the linear street
facing residential dwellings which are
characteristic of most properties on
star lane however there is a cluster of
bungalows within medicide which
represents a form of back land
development albeit with different
characteristics to the application site
so that which I pointed out to you and
go in medicide that's that's the area
that we're referring to previous
applications this site have not been
refused in relation to the proposal
being infill development or
out-of-character it's not considered
this represent a justified reason for
refusal here the bungalows are modest in
height with hipped roofs the separation
distances between proposed and existing
dwellings is considered sufficient to
ensure that no unreasonable harm to
amenity would be formed the minimum
garden area sizes and resident parking
bay requirements are adhere to whilst no
visitor parking spaces are provided this
would not be insisted upon for small
developments such as this County
highways have advice they would not
comment on a proposal onto a private
road it is not considered by officers
that the proposal would generate highway
safety concerns one meter separation
distance to the boundaries is provided
except to the northwest of prop one
which is not considered objectionable
and the overall design is considered
acceptable refuse bins will be brought
to the style on frontage on collection
day which is considered a suitable
arrangement there is a preserved tree
located within the site and Katie
so just in this location here there is a
preserved tree revised plan has been
provided showing the bungalows outside
of the route protection area of the tree
during the course of that applications
as you can see that that circles round
away just away from that bungalow and on
the basis of this the council's Arbor
culturalist it's not object and the
proposal is considered acceptable the
proposal would provide sufficient access
for an emergency vehicle as the private
drive width is 4.25 meters and they're
acquired with is 3.77
environment is so regards to
environmental sustainability the
bungalows would exceed the technical
housing standard minimum requirements a
condition is recommended to require
compliance with water efficiency
standards and energy performance looking
at ecology the site consists of
maintained gardens where the presence of
protected species is unlikely and
finally we found a flood risk the site
is within flood zone one concerns have
been raised regarding surface water
flooding it's considered that
appropriate drainage could be provided
at this site controlled by planning
condition to ensure no increase in
surface water flooding our Chairman this
application is recommended for approval
subject to conditions thank you have a
speaker on this this one Christine
Hansen
five minutes okay
Thank You committee and members I wish
to object to the planning application as
currently presented and request that
this should only be passed on further
additional conditions to those
recommended by the Planning agent I'd
like to point out the item two in the
officer report is being correct the
narrow frontage into star lane is
between numbers four and five not three
and five regarding material
well materiality to access I do not
agree that the representation in section
19 that the access road between numbers
four and five star lane would be a
minimum of four point two five meters
this is not objective and may require
variance to the title of number four
style lane which currently states
specifically under Section a two
property register that the passageway is
specifically ten feet in width 3.08
meter H is not sufficient to allow
safety service access such as fire
ambulance wheelchair disabled accessible
vehicles delivery vehicles and waste
disposal and if not permitted to print
to be varied it creates a conflagration
risk to neighboring properties and
outbuildings ice to suggest with
specific agreements of variants of the
passageway should be gained I do not
agree that reducing number Five's
driveway to one vehicle parking
to create a sufficient turning circle
makes parking requirements for a
three-bed house the proposal does not
include safe curbs or additional
lighting for pedestrian walkway down the
access road and stepping out of my
backside gates in furtherance of my
rights of way onto a traffic traffic
Troad is a risk to health and safety
additional car fumes in this morning
coat enclosure are also a risk to health
and Health and Safety and details of
safety measures and treatment to the
access road must be agreed prior to
commencement of works the planning agent
makes statement that boundaries are to
be 1 1.8 meters in height for the
fencing which will incorporate dark
patches into my garden and loss of light
to plants and seating area noise from
construction and additional traffic that
may cause irreparable harm to current
peace and tranquility should be remedied
by noise abatement heirship measures to
the neighboring boundaries prior to the
commencement of works the boundaries are
not of acoustic type star Lane is an
unadopted Road with potholes and further
compromised ation and degradation of the
road condition may occur due to heavy
load construction traffic and add
additional traffic the applicant should
propose remedy to road resurfacing prior
to the occupation of dwellings and
include provements to signage and
junction with bull Lane regardless of
proposed survey measures the sufficiency
of this measure on a high-density plane
should be subject to on-site testing and
verification via specific flood
prevention survey and measures which
must be carried out and be approved
prior to commencement current sewage
pipes are over 80 years old and no
specific consideration is delineated in
the application on whether this on
whether its current design
is sufficient for the additional load
from a potential additional 12 residents
need to go thanks foul and storm
drainage survey and design proposals
inclusive of CCTV survey before and
after construction and a soak away test
on the dense plane must be carried out
and be approved prior to commencement of
works additionally an invariable and
environmental survey impact survey must
be submitted and approved prior to
application and an approval of
commencement would have works
one more point on boundary treatment to
all effective neighbors that should be a
great prior to commencement of the
project such as party boundary
agreements if applicable if piled
foundations are within six metres of the
boundaries and it's the applicants duty
to pay your costs thank you just
reminding members there's a little bit
of information on the addendum with
regard to this one councillor dray
you've referred this one members will be
aware that I have called in his
application from the weekly list for two
reasons one being on the grounds of
inappropriate background development and
each other being in sufficient emergency
access to the site but regards to the
insufficient access to the site members
will note the previous referral date
detailed on a weekly list whereby the
refusal was due to two reasons relating
to the narrowness of the proposed of
vehicle access
item 19 on page nine one six states
that's proposed driveway access would be
capable of accommodating a car no
mention is made of the emergency
vehicles since since Morrison referral
of this item to this committee I have
received advice from officers that the
proposed driveway would meet the minimum
requirements for emergency
vehicles will be I would welcome members
comments on his adequacy and they may
wish to consider item 22 of the report
on page 91 six which states that refuge
bins were two beasts would be stored to
the rear of the gardens of the proposed
bungalows and won't have to be dragged
to the street frontage for collection
which may indicate that refuge
collection vehicles and for that matter
emergency vehicles may not be able to
maneuver or turn around within the
proposed tsiyon with regard to my second
reason for calling in the inappropriate
back at land development my
understanding is at section 5 of the NPP
F our item 70 states in part and I quote
plan should consider the case for
setting out policies to resist
inappropriate development of residential
gardens for example where development
would cause harm to the local area this
is of course a development of a
residential garden item 14 of the
offices report on page nine one four
states amongst other things that in
terms of relating to the existing Street
pattern and density of that of the
locality low locate locality the
proposed development would not reflect a
linear street facing residential
dwellings which are characteristic of
most of the most part of the properties
on style line item 14 goes on to state
that Meadow side which is a small
long-established purpose-built
cul-de-sac forms a type of backlund
arrangement which the proposal would
reflect although the report does confirm
that Meadow side does have a different
characteristic from the proposed site
including a shorter and wider access I
would suggest that this proposal is of
greater size and scope than that of
Metis than that of Meadow side and
cannot be compared with it
I asked the committee to consider that
this proposal be refused
for the reasons outlined thank you thank
you to any members wish to speak on this
one okay cancer soundly
Thank You chairman could the officer
give an indication as to the exact size
of the opening to stove lane and how the
refuge would was to be collected where
the refuge bins would be put in relation
to there will be four bins from the two
properties any one given time per week
and would it be where would they be put
exactly
so liver guards the actual size of the
access I can't confirm the specific size
where it meets style line but having
measured this distance before committees
night this along this length is 4.25
meters and because as part of the
application there is the extension being
removed to number 5 to allocate for that
extra width so I can't give you the
exact measurement of that point there
but that is 4.25 and with regards to the
actual positioning of the bins it would
be expected that it's likely at they'll
be in this location here because then it
would be away from that 4.25 meter width
so roughly in this position here on
collection day okay
I always tell members to stick stick to
the particular application that's in
front of us but on this occasion our
I'll remind members back I think it was
about 4 months ago where we had an
almost identical application in
Cheapside West where members were quite
concerned about a very very similar
style of access you deferred at the time
officers came back and it was
demonstrated that it was an acceptable
arrangement and in fact if memory
recalls it was in in fact a narrower
access than this one is proposing so in
terms of precedent whether you like the
principle or not we do have some very
recent example of an application like
that this that is that is demonstrated
as acceptable III I don't like the feel
of it but that's not a reason to refuse
it this does as officers of explained
comply and they have given a
recommendation for for approval so
unless any other members wish to speak
to castor Wilson thanks chase just a
question the inner officers report said
that the land slopes does it slope down
towards where the proposed bungalows are
going to
and I can get a sort of cite section
drawn up for you actually just to show
you that
[Music]
sorry I thought it can't quickly so at
the bottom there you can see thee that
plots pop 1 2 2 there is a slight drop
in land level going in that direction so
from so from south west down to
northeast you slightly mentioned it the
representations from highways seems to
be incomplete 34 highways except elation
sites like take down a private road and
therefore so I just I'm just going to
come back actually I think that's just
how the paragraph thing is a purpose
sort of appeared there because commonly
what they do is they they say the
application say site located in a pirate
Road and therefore their actual comment
then is that section below so it looks a
bit confusing like it's not finished a
sentence but that is looks to be one
point three down to zero from the right
from that my left to right is there any
surface water mitigation in on that
that's at the plan there's nothing that
they are proposing however that has been
raised as as concern by residents and as
a result we have suggested a condition
with regard to surface water drainage
the science of details to be submitted
to and agreed regarding that so we have
we have condition is recommended as part
of this application to get that
detailing members the recommendation for
approval is printed on nine point one
point fourteen going through the
following two pages those members in
favor of the approval plea
indicate those against thank you
that item is approved 9.2 members so
it's caught 210 now we've had we've got
we've still got some visitors and
speakers still here can I take your
agreement to continue the meetings on
this item is finished this is our last
item tonight we wouldn't normally stop
before 10 o'clock well you you if you
want yeah
just smaller German for two or three
minutes
Thank You chairman write this
application relates to a site to the Rio
student 8 st. Johns Road and the
proposal seeks planning permission to
alter and extend the existing buildings
at the rear of eight st. John's very
don't use these buildings as residential
properties these buildings are proposed
to comprise five one-bedroom
self-contained flats if we can move on
to one and two these plans just
illustrates or the elevations and the
layout of flats one and two if I can
show you plots three four five this is
the other building up set that will
comprise free flats the proposed
alterations of the building would be in
keeping with the scale form and
appearance of the existing buildings and
would not be harmful to the visual
amenity of the area the alterations
would not result in an increase height
of the buildings and therefore would not
result in an overbearing or
overshadowing impact and the price would
not amount to overlooking or loss of
privacy upon surrounding properties if
we can move and a centrally positioned
shared amenity space with a total area
of 106 quare metres would be provided
they would be a shortfall of 19 square
metres the deficit would equate to three
point eight square meters per flats
which is not a great deal the community
communal space is still considered to
provide a good sized functional space
for residential albeit slightly below
our requirements the development
proposed is a change of use rather new
build where a degree of flexibility can
be applied in this instance and an area
of storage for refuse bins would be
provided to the rear of unit one which
would be appropriate and appropriately
25 metres from st. John's Road and
therefore an appropriate place for a
refuse collection all flats proposed
comply with international technical
housing standards and the access would
be gained from st. John's Road and would
not have an impact on Harry safety the
site is proposed to lay out five car
parking spaces and this type of
development would require seven
parking spaces as there are two five
two-bedroom flats um however there is a
deficit of two spaces and which I
suppose you couldn't consider as visited
car parking spaces and the site would
not be able to provide with space but
the shortfall - or street car parking
space would not be considered
significant there are enough car parking
spaces proposed when the site's said
that proposed dwellings in addition
there are also no parking restrictions
on st. John's Road furthermore Essex
County County Highway Authority have
been consulted and commented and not
raised any objection to the proposed car
parking situation all the access on
John's Road and therefore final proposal
except or subjective conditions it is
acknowledged at the site currently
benefits from extent planning permission
and this is granted back in 2016 which
allowed a change of use to the premises
to provide one to patron property and
one free bedroom property we've
associated parking and amenity space and
yeah as I say it does benefit from
extent fund information that could still
be carried out in accordance with that
approval that has a similar car parking
situation whereby no visa to parking was
proposed and in this is found acceptable
the proposed development of its exit
form would have called with both
national and local planning policies and
adopted such reapplying documents and
therefore is recommending for an
approval subject to conditions date on
page eight point one of the agenda thank
you
[Music]
hello I'm Natalie Ellis and I'm the
owner of the property I thank you for
staying first of all I would just like
to point out that one people the
neighbors complained that the back of
the building
is used as their garden wall I have
actually been into the garden of 58's
Conroy Avenue which backs on to the
property and they showed me where there
are fence posts and where they used to
be an access way down the back of the
gardens and that has now gone where the
people have taken their fence posts out
so that actually you know that is that
it also says there about the bat survey
about survey was carried out in 2016
when the original planning that was
applied for it also mentions that
there's a badger set in the mill there
is no badger set in the mule I mean
they're regularly I store things in
there currently and there are definitely
no Badgers in the middle I would just
like to point out that it's actually
five one bid flats and not five to bid
flats and that it is on the exact same
footprint and that we've regards to the
parking there one bid flats I think they
will attract first-time buyers younger
people that perhaps couldn't afford one
car let alone two or older people that
might not have a car or may only have
one car as you mentioned we had we
already have planning permission for
houses a to bid in a three-bed which are
far more likely that the mother and
father if they are there would both have
a car and maybe an older teenage child
who could have a car and have friends
who would have a car and being teenagers
they could visit all hours of the night
so the options here if we do not get
this passed as 5/1 bed flats are to go
continue with the houses which aren't
really viable for us because they're too
big a house for the area as we would be
just renovating the buildings and
keeping the same space or to go back to
industrial which we could do and I
myself run an import-export business
which is currently located in Grange
Road in Southend where I do rent an
industrial unit and so you know it would
probably more be more feasible for me to
take the my business there and to rent
out the other units as they were
originally for industrial units however
I don't think that the location would
benefit from industrial and likewise I
don't think my business would really
benefit from being in an industrial area
but we have to do you know we have to
work it how we have to work it and if
with regards to the five one bid flats
it it does allow one one parking space
per flat these are integral inside the
buildings within the mill and any
visitors it is likely would possibly or
probably drive into the mill and park on
the drive you know driving to that area
rather than park outside because people
don't really like to walk there is a bus
stop just up the road and there is also
a high street just to the back of the
building and I think that is all with
regards to trucks and heavy goods going
up and down the side way into the mill
that you know that happened before there
were it was an old flour mill there have
been heavy trucks up and down I have had
heavy goods vehicles up there clearing
some of the area to enable the
councillors to come and look when they
visited the premises and I'm also
currently storing stuff for my work
there so we have had heavy goods
vehicles up and down thank you for your
time and I think that's all okay thank
you
Thank You chairman I have got a couple
of pictures on this one some of the
committee who attended the site visit a
couple of months back I'm pleased to say
could not park at the site there we are
that demonstrates the parking on one
side as you can see most of those cars
are on the pavement anyway and the next
picture please there we are just to give
you an idea okay if you just leave it
there for me
so referring to page nine point two
seven number thirty and yet again we
have a disagreement with our policies
and what's being okayed here
he says the parking center requires the
provision of at least one a per
one-bedroom flat plus a visitor space a
crime of noir point two five per flat
the office is already has mentioned that
there should be a provision of at least
seven spaces so when you think seven
spaces for visitors to those flats it's
still in my opinion not enough looking
at the current situation on this road
but seven would at least comply with
policy however when those seven were
configured they would have to also
ensure don't forget that there's enough
maneuverable room for each car to exit
and forward gear I think that's still
requirement the amenity space again the
officer touched on this that it is in
her where slightly under okay no I'm the
requirement is 25 square meters per flat
so again I'm getting a little bit
thinking what's the point of having
policy if we don't ask developers to
comply with it no Graham slightly under
but where will we stop if we give in to
these slightly under moments are we
going to go to a meter 10 meters give
them five meters to move around him
we've got policy for
reason select keep to that policy place
my last comment on this refers to page
nine point two seven from what I can see
it was about declaration was it a survey
or not perhaps the officers can advise
in 2016 but either way if you ever look
at the next two pictures there has been
film sent to us of bats and just that
one I do I think just one of them there
you are now that looks quite a nice
habitable place for bats if you actually
have a look and study and see the
location that bats like to make their
home in so an independent bat survey if
of course this is permissible and that's
it Thank You chairman yes thank chairman
it seems to be the theme this evening
that we've had issues with reports
coming from County highways and
particularly around our parking and
policies of what have you I will agree
with counsel McPherson again with
regards to our policy for parking we
should adhere to it we made the policy
let's add ear to it I'd also encourage
the assistant director the perhaps he
needs to secret meeting with County
highways to resolve this particular
issue no matter what application comes
forward and certainly been in the last
few meetings there seems to be a
consistent issue about what they bring
forward and advise us on we are
questioned there all the time we need to
find a way of resolving this and I think
you know that will make our job
considerably easier thank you
think sure it's a quick question really
actually there's already planning
permission for a different configuration
and so we know how many parking spaces
will be necessary for the that the
approved scheme yeah in 2016 an
application was approved or for the
change of use of the buildings for one
two bedroom and one free bedroom these
are both houses and so we were required
to car parking spaces per two-bedroom
plus properties of four would be
required for this development
I don't have the plans for me and to
have a look at what was proposed but
they would have required for car parking
spaces for this particular development
at that time and I know the offices
referred to in in her report that that a
similar amount of car parking was
proposed and there was a deficit with
regards to visitor spaces and so I would
imagine that we've out seen the plans
that the actual car parking for the
dwellings itself were provided however
from reading this it sounds like the
visitor car parking spaces wasn't
provided and like I said that was
acceptable in 2016 with the car parking
spaces I'm not really happy about the
statement made that a young couple may
not have or may only have one car
because they're you know they can't
afford to buy a property and things like
that
considering that you can get a couple of
secondhand cars for around about two or
three hundred pounds and if you really
do need one or you your partner has got
one for business then that will need a
car parking spaces well whether it be a
vein or a business that he might have to
use a vehicle of some sorts so on that
basis really the car parking is
inadequate so I feel on that on that
basis alone thank you
Thank You chairman I was a member of the
the site visit on this and parking was
particularly difficult
we've already refused one application
this evening for having one parking
space less surely would be a nonsense to
approve this one that has two pathways
two parking spaces less than is required
thank you pushing the parking on to some
Jones Road which is not the best this
and pictures there as I said on the site
visit parking was not good people come
and park getting through they are you
see car parks on the on the pavements
I've personally thickness should be
fused on parking because it's just not
enough for the visitors
I think it was pointed out to us as well
that the was it the room sizes weren't
were just undersized or whatever it was
the undersized I think it was the
private amenity space the garden areas
lenity space that that's right that's
correct so that that's undersized as
well so it there are two things and
we've got photographic evidence that
there is a problem in any case so on
that basis I think we should refuse it